madame la Présidente
chers collègues l'Union européenne va
faire cette semaine une avancée majeure
nous sommes en effet la première
institution le premier continent au
monde a posé des règles pour
l'intelligence artificielle ce texte est
ambitieux il est le fruit de deux ans de
travail de la Commission et du Parlement
il a été remis sur le métier pour
répondre au bouleversement de l'IA
générative comme Tchad jibetty il va
établir des responsabilités pour les
concepteurs et fournisseurs en
classifiant les risques
pour garantir à nos concitoyens des
iadines de confiance qui respectent nos
valeurs c'est un début cette révolution
doit nous amener à des réflexions quasi
philosophiques sur l'avenir de notre
civilisation en tant qu'humaniste je
demande du nia toujours encadré par
l'intelligence humaine il faut former à
la maîtrise de ces outils pour innover
et pour transformer nos emplois et non
les détruire et nous devons rapidement
disposer d'un cadre pour la création
culturelle qui s'appuie sur les acquis
de la directive droit d'auteur et qu'il
a complète pour que la machine ne
remplace jamais ce qu'il y a d'unique
dans la sensibilité humaine et que les
droits d'auteurs soient préservés